hi I'm RIA and this is my recipe for a
Korean cookies so I was looking on the
internet and found this really cool
cookie called the Chaka Chaka cookies
Chaka Chaka is onomatopoeia for shaking
noise in Japanese so when you shake
something and make knowledge that it's
Chaka the person made a true cookie is
glued together and put sprinkles inside
so when you shake it you can see the
sprinkles inside moving and it was very
cute the recipe doll looks very
complicated they use the special kind of
sugar called the polyphenols which is
not so during regular grocery stores so
I wanted to make it but make it very
simple so everyone can make a home
that's something I always wanted to
include in my video that's something
everyone can make a home that's the
great thing about tasty I think and
making this cookie was very fun I made
this video for tasty Junya initially and
I had the opportunity to work with kids
it was very fun to cook with little
girls especially the child actor I
walked through it she was so impressed
she told me I could be a chef in the
future and I should open the restaurant
and it was very cute and sweet I was
thinking maybe I could use store-bought
candy and melt it there is also another
cookie called a stained glass cookie
which is very popular
so I use the Jolie launcher instead of
the special sugar and - two kids
together with white chocolate so it
tastes better when I was reading comment
I saw some audience said Jolie launcher
it's too hard so if you buy into it you
might break your piece but when you bake
a Jolie launcher spread very thinly so
don't worry about breaking your teeth
you won't break your piece and look out
for you this feeling become viral and I
saw a lot of people make it I also saw
some people made it for a bake sale and
it's a great feeling when someone
actually make it and have fun with it
I think also shakashaka cookies is a
cute name for Japanese cookie but if you
translate it it's become shake shake
cookie which it's not so catchy
it was our general manager uh Sharif who
was sitting next to me and said that
looks like an a Korean so that's why I
named it so don't be afraid of breaking
your teeth it's actually tasty kids love
that and you can customize it you can
feel loved that are in there and make it
fancy make it fancy make
fancy
[Music]
[Applause]